dans un exquis et 24 autres officiels
craignant de haut rang 1 seraient
traqués par des milices qui aurait pour
unique but de les éliminer à leurs
trousses aurais tu étais lancé le fameux
groupe wagner considéré comme l'armé
secrète de poutine on parle aussi
d'autres forces spéciales tchétchènes on
en parle notamment avec avec xenia
bolshakova bonjour xenia journaliste co
réalisatrice d'un dernier documentaire
wagner l'armée de l'ombre de poutine
alors on va évidemment voir un extrait 1
de ce document extrêmement fouillée et
captivant évidemment il ya très peu de
documents comme le vôtre qui arrive à
avoir accès déjà assez à ses hommes de
lons et ses mercenaires une première
question sur sur wagner c'est évidemment
la plus connue des milices secrète de
poutine a est apparue la première fois
pour la première fois dans le donbass
était en 2014 à l'époque c'est vrai que
ça faisait pas forcément beaucoup parler
effectivement alors le wagner le groupe
wagner n'est dans le donbass à l'époque
on est de terre en 2013 2014
un certain dimitri oussekine qui est un
ancien des renseignements militaires
russes du géant rue quitte l'armée est
réuni autour de lui un certain nombre de
vétérans des forces spéciales dmitry
lipkin pour nom de guerre wagner et
c'est pour ça que ce groupe ce premier
groupe va s'appeler wagner mais c'est
comme ça qu'ils s'appellent entre eux
que ça pas du tout d'existence juridique
d'existence légale à ce moment là au
début ils sont ils sont très peu ils
sont très peu ils sont cinq ans en
pleine au début ils sont 40 après ils
vont grimper en on y aura peu près 300
hommes qui vont agir dans la république
de donetsk est dans la république de
lougansk est les premières missions de
ses hommes quelles sont elles et bien
c'est d'éliminer des chefs séparatistes
trop indépendant aux yeux du kremlin ils
sont envoyés pour exécuter des leaders
séparatistes qui ne suivraient pas la
ligne officielle russe et donc c'est ça
la première mission alors envoyé par qui
s'est un peu toute la question qui se
pose et c'est un peu la trame aussi de
votre documentaire
notamment c'est un groupe privé wagner
et le kremlin et vladimir poutine se
défendent absolument aucun homme n'est
donnée par par le pouvoir russe s'est
pas vraiment ce que disent d'aix wagner
que vous avez pu interroger enfin
écouter l'un d'entre eux
et cette armée aujourd'hui elle peut
agir sans l'accord du gouvernement
non car elle est totalement équipées par
le gouvernement
les hommes qui sont mobilisés sont
souvent des réservistes de l'armée
ils sont équipés de tout le nécessaire
nourri habillé
le transport et la logistique utilisés
sont ceux du ministère de la défense
vont les envoyer sur les lieux où ils
doivent mener des opérations de combat
avant vivre là c'est bel et bien une
filiale gouvernementale
une structure de l'état russe
voilà une armée privée qui agirait à la
solde du kremlin c'est évidemment tous
les retours que vous avez pu avoir
pendant pendant sept longues années et
demi de travail
en tout cas alors bien sûr il ya pas de
lien direct entre des mercenaires de
wagner et vladimir poutine en personne
et c'est très difficile de remonter ce
fil en revanche qu'on a pu démontrer
documents à l'appui c'est qu'il y avait
des liens plus ou moins directe quand
même direct avec le ministère de la
défense russe les hommes de wagner
s'entraîne sur une base qui s'appelle
molfino qui jouxte une base du
renseignement militaire dans certains
pays où ils sont déployés comme la libye
ils ont utilisé des avions de chasse
quel milices privées quel groupe de
mercenaires peu utilisé des avions de
chasse de chasse qui appartiennent à un
état donc les fameux mig-29 donc voilà
ça c'est ce qu'on a essayé nous de
prouver
à travers des documents à travers ces
témoignages aussi
il y avait un autre élément important
c'est que
les groupes 20 les mercenaires ne sont
jamais déployées dans des zones qui ne
suivraient pas la carte des intérêts
russes ça c'est fascinant vous avez eu
accès à justement à ces documents qui
indiquent pays par pays l'état des lieux
des forces en présence on parle
évidemment du ben ali on a on a traité
ici sur cette antenne le retrait de
barkan du mali ont dit que c wagner qui
va prendre la relève à à bamako qui va
en tout cas servir le gouvernement
malien pour l'aider à faire régner
l'ordre dans le pays ce qui est ce qui
est contesté vous avez eu accès à ces
documents qui indiquent notamment voilà
le principal obstacle au mali c'est la
présence des forces françaises ça ce
sont des documents qui datent de 2018
des documents internes aux structures de
priego ginon qu'elle gagne prigogine qui
est le les gars kif qui financerait la
force wagner et dans ces documents sont
établis déjà des stratégies
d'implantation du groupe wagner dans
différents pays africains notamment
on parle évidemment dans ce document et
des mentions de la france de la force
française qui pourrait être un obstacle
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
surtout le détail de l'intérêt de la
russie à s'y implanter dans ces pays en
première ligne enfin ce qu'on voit
d'abord c'est les ressources ressources
minières les ressources minières les
ressources naturelles pourquoi les
russes veulent s'implanter dans ces pays
c'est avant tout pour exploiter les
mines d'or les mines de diamants et
c'est ce qu'on a vu nous en nous
déplaçant notamment en centrafrique mais
à bangui en voix dans votre document ce
qui n'est pas sans risque ce qui n'est
pas sans risque évidemment on dit la
rumeur circule et les autorités
ukrainiennes
se rappelle assez régulièrement
que plusieurs centaines d'hommes de
wagner auraient été débarqués d'afrique
serait arrivé à kiev et serait en train
de traquer et le président et lenski et
24 aux membres du gouvernement se taille
d'ailleurs on a un peu dit plus ce week
end il aurait déjà réchappé à trois
tentatives d'assassinât ce que vous avez
des informations là-dessus est ce que ça
vous paraît plausible si ça me paraît
plausible mais je suis pas du tout en
mesure de l'affirmer d'abord on ne
connaît jamais la nature exacte des
missions des hommes de wagner on les
connaît après une fois qu'elles ont été
accomplis ce qu'on sait pour le coup
avec mac os réalisatrice alexandra
jousset c'est que depuis plusieurs mois
effectivement des mercenaires qui était
déployé en centrafrique et en libye ont
été envoyés en ukraine il ya encore
trois semaines plusieurs avions
partaient
chaque semaine de la base d'al joufra
quai dans le sud de la libye qui
ramenait des mercenaires en russie pour
pouvoir rejoindre les soldats de l'armée
régulière russe en ukraine quelle est la
nature de leur mission de ce qu'on en
sait de ce que nous disent nos sources
c'est d'abord d'assister la police
militaire dans les régions séparatistes
et dans un deuxième temps plusieurs
hommes ont été envoyés dans le crâne de
l'ouest pour mener des opérations de
sabotage c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que
telle ou telle installation électrique
arrête de marché que les centrales
s'arrête
est ce qu'il y a une mission
d'assassinât ciblé à ce stade là je suis
incapable de vous le dire je peux pas
l'exclure mais c'est très difficile
affirmé mais ça vous paraît plausible
c'est quand même ce qu'on va ce qu'on va
retenir ces hommes qui sont donc a
priori probablement présent en ukraine
sont sont pointés du doigt par l'onu
c'est pas nouveau il ya un dernier
rapport qui date de 2000 21 qui fait
état d'exactions notamment
en afrique certains ce que vous avez pu
interroger en disent un peu plus sur les
projets de vladimir poutine les projets
du régime russe face à l'occident on va
on va écouter tout de suite ce nouvel
extrait et puis on y revient juste après
maignan catégorie on n'est pas des têtes
brûlées qui sont prêtes moyennant de
l'argent à exécuter de pauvres africains
on a rien à [__] de renseignements sur
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
notre cible c'est le monde occidental
avec son idéologie et ses valeurs
nous sommes élevés différemment nous
avons une autre vision du monde
nous serons toujours en conflit avec
l'occident
[Musique]
notre cible et on comprend aussi celui
du régime de vladimir poutine c'est le
monde occidental son idéologie et ses
valeurs ça fait évidemment écho à ce
qu'on est sûr en train de vivre
aujourd'hui en ukraine bien sûr en fait
que ce que nous dit vassili à ce moment
là c'est qu'il est il est prêt à se
battre pour ce néo impérialisme russe
dont vladimir poutine s'est fait le
porte-voix aujourd'hui quand on entend
le président russe dire vouloir
restaurer le fameux monde ruches en
unissant les russes les ukrainiens les
biélorusses dans un seul et même pays
alors bien sûr il n'a jamais été
question de reconstruire l'union
soviétique mais clairement il est
question de reconstruire un empire sous
la forme sous laquelle on l'a connu
avant la chute de l'union soviétique et
ses ambitions impériales en tout cas moi
ça m'avait vraiment marquer quand on
parlait avec avait avec vassili donc ce
ce mercenaire disait moi aujourd'hui
je suis prêt à mourir je suis prêt à me
battre notamment en ukraine pour
récupérer les terres que mon pays a
perdu donc c'est un discours qui est on
dit souvent on dit souvent que les
ruches n'adhère pas forcément discours
de vladimir poutine est bien une
catégorie de russes dont font partie les
anciens militaires dont font partie des
hommes comme vassili les nostalgiques du
régime soviétique siens 6 les anciens
aussi qu'ils adhèrent beaucoup en fait à
7 à cette vision néo impérial et ça on
entend beaucoup ces jours-ci ouais alors
c'est une vision évidemment qui est
véhiculée à coup de propagande et ça
rassure vous l'expliquer extrêmement
bien dans votre document ça fait partie
d'un des piliers au point qui a même une
un organe de presse quasiment qui a été
constituée pour créer des documents
vidéo de propagande
qui sont actuellement diffusée aux
russes aujourd'hui alors il ya plusieurs
il ya plusieurs types de propagande bien
d'abord celle de la télévision d'état
russe qui reprend mot pour mot les
communiqués de presse du kremlin ou du
ministère-clef l'année dernière la
dernière à couvrir ce conflit
aujourd'hui en russie alors elle ne
couvre pas le conflit construire qu'il
n'y a pas de couverts à couvrir mais en
tout cas c'est l'une des seules qui en
tout cas peut en parler et communiquer
sur le conflit les médias d'opposition
soit fermées soit décider de d'éluder
les l'idée cette crise et puis là tu es
la télévision d'état et les médias
officiels en parle d'une certaine façon
le mot guerre est interdite on n'a pas
le droit de critiquer les forces armées
russes on n'a pas droit de perdre des de
parler des pertes de l'armée russe
aujourd'hui dans les médias officiels
la terminologie est la suivante c'est
une intervention c'est une opération
militaire pour des nazifié l'ukraine et
pour venir en aide aux populations du
dombass le mot guerre est interdit et
après il ya d'autres organes de presse
comme celui dont on parle dans le film
qui s'appelle ria fans qui fait partie
d'un groupe de 147 médias qui s'appelle
médias patriotes qui est dirigé et
financé toujours par la même personne
ait gagné prigogine qui est le financier
également du groupe wagner donc il ya
plusieurs il a plusieurs plusieurs
cordes à son cou plusieurs a plusieurs
cordes à son arc parc
il ya plusieurs axes en fait il ya bien
sûr la dimension militaire donc on se
bat on désinforme et puis on s'enrichit
parce que el ghany prigogine aussi faut
pas l'oublier c'est ce qu'on appelle un
entrepreneur d'influencé quelqu'un qui
gagne de l'argent aussi dans les
terrains où la force l'anr est déployée
l'enjeu financier évidemment est énorme
qui est en jeu et avec l'ukraine aussi
cette question que je posais dans les
titres est ce qu on est en train de
redessiner les rapports de l'occident
vis-à-vis de la russie on parle alors
évidemment les commentateurs examine
toutes les options possibles on a
beaucoup parlé de cette nouvelle ère qui
s'ouvre est peut-être de ces rapports de
ces échanges entre leh et russes et
l'asie qui pourraient plus se tourner
vers l'asie demain votre avis à vous qui
avez aussi été correspondante en russie
pendant de longues années moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on reviendra plus jamais
en arrière qui a vraiment une page qui
est en train de se tourner
ça va être extrêmement difficile
de dans le temps dans les semaines dans
les mois à venir de parler à vladimir
poutine comme quand on lui a parlé
précédemment enfin jeu c'était déjà
compliqué on se souvient de la séquence
avec nicolas sarkozy quand il vient
d'être élu et qui se retrouve face à la
presse on avait cru qu'il avait vu un
peu trop de votre cas c'était pas
vraiment le cas il avait juste été
terrorisés par le président russe donc
non bien sûr ça va être de plus en plus
compliquées et et ça va être aussi très
compliqué pour les russes qui reste en
russie c'est à dire que là aujourd'hui
c'est un instinct pays qui qui va tomber
dans un isolement total
moi j'ai l'impression de voir sort de
nouveau rideau de fer qui tombe les gens
ne peuvent plus sortir du pays parce que
l'espace aérien est fermé économiquement
c'est un pays qui va être sous blocus
c'est aussi un blocus informationnel
parce qu'il est impossible aujourd'hui
de l'intérieur de savoir vraiment ce qui
se passe à l'extérieur et on a cette
élite dirigeante à la tête du pays
vladimir poutine et la cinquantaine de
proches qui l'entourent dans son cercle
proche qui prennent qui prennent des
décisions
irréversibles pour les rapports
internationaux alors il ya toujours
l'espoir de la négociation la diplomatie
continue de travailler on voit qu
emmanuel macron continue de parler à
vladimir poutine moi je pense que c'est
très important ne pas couper justement
ce canal là mais c'est très difficile de
prévoir irréversible pour nombre
d'ukrainiens aussi on